oh she said oh she said oh yeah she did
all holla love hey what's going on you
two
if y'all have not heard the news holy
[ __ ] and my song likes kpop what is your
latest obsession what's the thing you're
obsessed with these days k-pop k-pop I
know I know this is not global news but
it's [ __ ] crazy to me that Emma Stone
loves cake pop you know why cuz I don't
come cheap I'm not saying that this
shit's bad and I'm not saying that a
certain point that I did not like it
myself because it did when I was younger
I was into h.o.t Pantene and then Giotto
Shinhwa achieve the oldest Orion that's
right I tried to be a thug while like in
Korean pop music which made no sense
there's all those fools a lot girls
they're so [ __ ] pretty what am I
supposed to say now we all know after
that homosexuality is not a choice but
if any of you out there just have an
inkling that you might be gay just just
go for a creamy you know what's so
[ __ ] up like when k-pop was getting
huge people had this weird perception of
what Korean guys were supposed to look
like all the Asian girls assumed that
every single Korean dude was supposed to
be pretty as hell got the double eyelid
smooth as skin and then my Quasimoto
last showed up on the scene life how are
you doing
it was the most annoying thing on earth
but I'll tell a girl I'm Korean and she
want to believe me Oh Korean name not
get too ugly to be Korean [ __ ] but ever
still liking kpop shows how powerful
this [ __ ] is and people don't even know
the [ __ ] words the healthy songs but
they get so hyped over it y'all remember
those Korean news that bit off that og
MACO song those [ __ ] are
rapping in Korean but people still get
hyped about the [ __ ] and when they rap
in English even I don't know what the
[ __ ] they're saying on the water swaps
strap on the watch flap [ __ ] is an
underwater squat [ __ ]
I think her like in kpop makes it that
much more realistic that she and I could
probably one day get together you know a
lot of guys do that when we find out
that you and I have something in common
we think we're soul mates you drink
water so do I gave up just happens to be
one of those things that you don't need
to understand it there's a certain vibe
and a feel to it you don't know why you
like it and you already know that the
music videos are one of the most
expensive don't miss things that you'll
ever see on earth I'm just saying Emma
if you like kpop so much why don't you
pop gas on over here I thought of that
job for 15 minutes and it's still not
funny
it's weird because I had this weird
thing for redheads I don't know why
because you guys are like a genetic
anomaly like your eyes are blue your
hair is red you ain't really supposed to
exist to [ __ ] so maybe that's why I want
you you rare girl but we all know as
guys the reason why guys like redheads
is because we could we automatically
know your nipples are pink
I'll let the world tell you that we
can't be together you should know why
people and Korean people make cute as
babies we make kites because I baby so
cute they just fly a mean Aryan